mari and holds uppal's winter tires are
getting old there's a simple test with a
euro coin if the gold edge disappears
between the treads the tire is okay but
these tires won't last the whole winter
lorien was already warned last year that
she needed new tires till now she'd
always bought them from a dealer but now
she's also seen they can be ordered
cheaply online mauryan wants to save
money but doesn't want to compromise on
quality so that means buying tires on
the internet or maybe not perhaps the
dealer would be a safer bet we take the
test what quality is available for what
price automotive expert Peter mealies is
with us to take a look Peter says not
all winter tires are the same dealers
often want to unload them as quickly as
possible and sometimes the tires are
also stored incorrectly and that affects
the quality mauryan is suspicious will
she really get brand new tires or is
shopping online only a matter of price
for our test she ordered three sets of
tires with a good test rating the tires
can be delivered directly to the repair
shop of the buyer's choice for
installation perhaps even the one around
the corner she says that's a great
service does this I machines opal solace
it all sounds wonderful the tires should
be here in three days meanwhile Marianas
visiting local tire dealers to check
prices and she's brought Pater along for
his expert opinion the to go undercover
posing as normal buyers they asked to
see the same tires they bought online
and asked for a price quote yeah
a quick glance is enough for Peter to
know this tire is from the latest
production and the quality is right
there's one surprise the dealer doesn't
have a tire model that is being sold
online as brand new he says it's last
year's model he offers the other tires
for a competitive price his prices are a
little bit more than online but they
include installation and disposal of the
old tires these extras cost more if you
buy them from the internet Peter says
the results were good the advice was
technically correct and presented
clearly the d-o-t numbers on the tires
identified them as brand new and the
price was also good my own says that as
a non-expert she still felt confident in
the work shot she was able to understand
what the dealer said and she now knows
what to look for being able to examine
the merchandise getting good advice and
a sense of trust these are things Peter
says identify a good garage so far a set
of tires from the online shop cost on
average 30 euros less than at the dealer
around the corner three days later the
online orders arrive in our experts
workshop let's see what they've sent us
the ice is entire Peter tells Mari and
the online tires are here and they're
right on schedule and now he says we
have to find out how good these tires
really are two tires are clearly one
year old while the third is brand new it
looks like Mario got last year's
leftovers tires that already have one
year less service life ahead of them at
least the European approval is correct
the ECE seal is the EU safety standard
finally Peter mealies checks whether the
tires have been stored correctly in one
case he makes a worrying discovery he
says the tire is completely deformed the
tread surface and even the whole side
are completely out of place it's obvious
the tire has been stored and correctly
that means the tire will likely show a
strong imbalance Peter says he would not
install this tire peter has of course
checked each of the four tires there's
no further sign of storage damage and
the labeling is correct for all sets of
tires our conclusion the dealer has
thoroughly impressed both mariyaan and
our experts but to internet stores sold
older tires and there was damage from
incorrect storage buyers should be
cautious when shopping online peter has
one more important tip come he says now
is the time to deal with winter tires
they are still plentiful appointments
are no problem and prices are good
mauryan has now installed the winning
tires she knows that when it comes to
tires you should really know what you're
doing if you plan to buy online and if
you shop based on price alone you can
quickly hit the skids
you